bienvenue devant Télématin ce lundi 1er
mai on est ravier avec Jean-Baptiste de
passer la matinée même toute la semaine
avez-vous et oui on peut le dire salut
bande de chroniqueurs vous allez bien
vous allez bien Olivier mais super
regardez il y a des fleurs partout on
s'assant le muguet sur le plateau
c'est vrai que ça sent fort et dis-moi
elles sont elles sont fraîches moi mon
brun est frais c'est une contrepèterie
je remercie quand même la production de
m'avoir armée une petite couronne
mortuaire
tu m'as fait énormément plaisir
ça me fait plaisir
on l'a tant aimé une chose importante si
vous cueillez un bras de muguet qu'il y
a 13 clochettes c'est le bonheur éternel
voilà donc
non
par terre dans les bois où il y a
potentiellement des araignées des bêtes
chelous non je les regarde soyons aigris
soyons heureux
au Havre le rassemblement national a
voulu rénover ce traditionnel
rendez-vous du 1er mai sur scène le
discours reste le même celui de la
défense du peuple face à ce qui est
considéré comme une double menace les
Français ont le sentiment
ceux d'en haut et ceux d'en bas à une
oligarchie et à une voyoucratie plus
d'un millier de militants RN sont
attendus le service de sécurité du parti
est là des grandes bâches blanches aussi
pour empêcher le regard indiscret des
caméras sauf que
le dossier est intéressant de Muriel je
vous le dis Muriel parce que les trois
autres dossiers sont vraiment nuls
je parle de ceux de Ruben pierre
la tête qu'ils font dans ces cas-là donc
là on est dans un bus scolaire au
Michigan donc aux États-Unis la
conductrice en fait et bah est en train
d'appeler ses responsables pour leur
dire qu'elles sont pas très bien qu'elle
est prise de nausées elle s'évanouit et
là et bah il y a un garçon qui arrive
qui prend le contrôle du volant et qui
réussit à arrêter le véhicule avant de
demander à ses camarades d'appeler à
l'aide écouter
appeler les secours maintenant
appelez
Grand Prix d'Azerbaïdjan à Bakou
victoire de Sergio Perez devant vers cet
aprèm mais mais l'image folk on
retiendra c'est celle-ci la course n'est
pas terminée il reste un tour au leader
Sergio Perez regardez le français
Esteban décide lui de repasser par la
voix des stands il arrive à bloc et va
tomber sur une nuée de gens qui n'ont
rien à faire là du personnel d'équipe et
des photographes ici en plein milieu ça
aurait pu être un drame et puis regardez
cette image de sport avec une chute
spectaculaire sur le Tour de Bretagne
survenu hier lors de la sixième étape
entre Chateaubriand et Plancoët la
chaussée couverte debout apprécie pitié
le peloton dans une chute presque
collective plusieurs coureurs ont été
contraints à l'abandon 4 ont été
transportés à l'hôpital l'étape a été
annulée l'événement culturel du moment
je parle bien évidemment du tout nouveau
roman de Bruno Le Maire fugue américain
un livre qui a suscité un petit tollé
puisqu'il y parle entre autres d'anus
dilaté
c'est comme ça alors j'ai donné
l'extrait du livre de Bruno Le Maire
achat j'ai pété et je l'ai demandé
d'écrire un texte sur la réforme des
retraites dans le même style et voilà ce
qui est dit et les téléspectateurs qui
n'ont peut-être pas lu cette page vous
comprendrez ça tient après la
promulgation pendant deux ou trois jours
je suis sous tension comme jamais je
m'enflamme et lui arriver de soulever
son dossier bleu clair pour montrer ses
graphiques tu as vu comme ils sont
élevés aujourd'hui alors quoi qu'on
pense du style de Bruno Le Maire sachez
que c'est quand même son cinquième livre
en quatre ans un rythme impressionnant
d'autant plus qu'à côté de son métier
d'écrivain Bruno Le Maire pratique aussi
le hobby de ministre de l'économie
tu as vu Oscar il le retirait totalement
dévoiler dans le dévoilant dans les
creux des pages des petits points rouges
comme des indicateurs négatifs il me
tournait le dos il se jetait sur la
table de réunion il me montrait le creux
sombre de son déficit tu viens Oscar je
suis prêt à réformer comme jamais je
suis une cougar j'ai toujours ATT
iré les mois
j'assume
d'aimer et d'attirer les hommes plus
jeunes que moi et de mieux m'entendre
aussi avec eux c'est comme ça
[Musique]
les hommes plus jeunes ou viennent vers
moi parce que souvent on pense pas que
j'ai 48 ans en général on me donne 35
vous avez ailleurs et ben ailleurs a
donné ailleurs alors les aïeux c'est
tous les ancêtres ça va jusqu'à
Cro-Magnon mais les aïeuls c'est
précisément les quatre grands-parents
oui c'est obligatoire un biologiquement
même dans une partouze il y en a quatre
dans la région où j'habite on nous a
confondus avec ma fille ou alors penser
qu'on était seul plutôt que mère et
fille quoi en fait la nuit des
expériences d'hommes qui nous ont dragué
toutes les deux
peut-être que si j'avais utilisé des
crèmes anti-rides et tout ça
s'arrêter là pour l'instant tout va bien
et j'en utilise même pas il y a quelques
années j'imagine que c'était pas du tout
en vogue
c'était aux années sans salle des ventes
au non non c'est moche
oui aujourd'hui c'est moche
La Cri du cœur alors là c'est sorti là
mais
mais ça plaît au bureau selon la loi
vous avez le droit de manger un sandwich
devant votre ordinateur boire une bière
ou aucun des deux
aucun des deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez consommé de
l'alcool madame
est-ce que vous acceptez de souffler
vous voulez une prise de sang donc on
souffle
pas dessus soyez polis ça changera
l'alcool est prohibé au boulot sauf le
vent la bière le cidre et le poire et
par contre vous n'avez pas le droit
d'être en état d'ivresse par contre
selon la loi il est interdit de laisser
les travailleurs prendre leur repas dans
les locaux affectés au travail et je dis
ça l'employeur risque
3750 euros d'amende
secrétaire voilà et toi tu fais quoi
sportif
[Musique]